hello everyone
welcome back to the collider youtube
channel for some south by southwest 2021
coverage
right now we are talking about midnight
or off season and we have the team
behind the film with us mickey jocelyn
joe huge congratulations
on this one i love covering all of your
stuff so i get especially excited when
another one comes out that i absolutely
love and
guys did it again thank you thank you
thank you thank you very much
all right mickey i'm coming your way
first because i think this might be one
of the longer gaps for you
between films so what was it about off
season that required uh
a little more prep time yeah well you
know it's funny because
i in i went and i did a television show
for
the shutter a a show called the core
which was
you know a different way to kind of look
at movie making and i usually would have
done another movie in that time
and then you know after that i kind of
had the luxury to be able to sit
and think about what i wanted to do and
develop
you know ideas for things that were
living in my brain for a long time and
so with this one i knew that i want to
do a movie in florida so figuring out
the logistics behind that
uh it requires a certain you know some
pretty big asks like you know an actual
bridge that rises up and locks the
character in um
and just all of these little elements
and this was the first movie i'd ever
done where i actually drew the entire
film
and edited it beforehand and so that
when we started shooting we were able to
kind of break those rules
uh so yeah so i mean it definitely feels
like a longer length between my other
movies but
it was really the first movie that i was
able to make where i was like all right
i'm ready to kind of take that next step
you know anything about that process and
experience that you're gonna hold on to
for your next phone
sure yeah i mean a lot of things and you
know one of the things that i really
kind of
this was the first one where we were
like well let's plan to shoot at
particular times of day
at magic hour for a lot of moments but i
definitely do think there's a
tremendous value to drawing and planning
as much as you possibly can
so you can break those rules on set and
this was uh you know this one was a real
pleasure to
kind of get in and actually re-edit well
with what we shot because we knew we
had so much stuff so much more you know
i guess
i have to ask one more follow-up now
what is an example
obviously a non-spoiler territory here
of a rule that you broke
and it wound up serving the film better
in the end oh well
i mean i definitely feel like the great
thing about
the way this movie was scheduled was we
were able to
have jocelyn and joe basically be the
first thing
up in the movie and so just to be able
to say
you know the movie when you cut it on
paper and you design it on paper it
becomes this very rigid
thing and then when you give it to these
actors who are really brilliant
at you know at living in this kind of
moment you get to watch and see and kind
of plan things accordingly
and so really it was able to take on
this sort of naturalism and this sort of
more spontaneity in the first week that
might not have been there
if we shot them last which was really
quite a thrill
all right jocelyn i'm coming to you next
because you've worked with some of my
absolute favorite genre directors out
there so two-fold question for you
first are there any shared traits that
all of the horror greats have
in your eyes and then also what is it
about mickey's process that makes him
stand out from the pack
i think something that's universal about
um all the directors i've had the
privilege of working with is just how
much
they love cinema and how much they use
cinema as a language like you know
they'll be referencing
moods or ideas or misdirects or whatever
it is a style or a tone but they're
using
film to describe what that is so i
always learn a lot
when i'm on these sets and on this set
there were three directors so i got to
hear
a lot of you know filmmaking uh shop
talk
and then mickey i would say i mean he
just has this
pure enthusiasm and exuberance
um on set he was just so happy and it
just makes everybody else feel relaxed
and
free to create and it was just a really
cool
ecosystem like the whole set uh the
whole all the departments and
i know he's worked with a lot of the
same people um so that was
also just felt like a family right away
um
but yeah mickey is just he just goes for
it like
i think he was always saying it gives
him life like he loves to find the
interesting
things that you you know the unexpected
things
um so it's just really inspiring to be
around him and work with him
and joe as someone who has had great
success
directing many of features in the micro
budget realm having worked with mickey
now is there anything that he did on
this film that you're kind of gonna i
guess
back pocket and take on to your next
directing gig
uh yeah for sure i like it's one of the
reasons i love acting in other people's
movies i'm constantly stealing tricks
and you know i get to watch someone else
do it and be like oh okay cool
if i ever do that i'm gonna do those
three things and not that fourth thing
um but uh
yeah you know honestly my biggest
takeaway was
watching mickey be a problem solver like
on a movie this
big with this many moving pieces and
also
as mickey was saying he had storyboarded
the film out ahead of time he knew it
really well
um and those things are around and then
occasionally you lose a location
um the light changes unexpectedly um
some piece of equipment isn't working
i thought i was so impressed with
mickey's ability to adjust
and it really reminded me i think that's
like
one of the greatest skills a filmmaker
can have
come in prepared and then remain totally
flexible because
you're working in the real world we're
not on a studio
we don't have complete control over the
technical elements of this
and i never saw him lose his cool it was
a really
inspiring experience to kind of show up
okay plan a is obviously not going to
happen mickey had like plans b
c and d ready to go plus a good attitude
about it
and so that was my big takeaway i was
kind of like all right that's the right
way to do it
keep your cool keep a positive attitude
be ready to change at the last minute
it's going to work out if only everybody
did that it would be good vibes 24
7 around this is kind of random but
mickey and jocelyn did you two happen to
meet when you both worked on insidious
chapter two because sometimes i'll like
put in the the imdb
field the collaboration thing and i
thought this was your one and only time
working together and that title popped
up too
i i well i was just uh i was like a desk
assistant for blum
so i had heard jocelyn was in
insidious two i was like oh that's
brilliant casting of course absolutely
uh but i don't think and if if we had
cross path i would have been too
starstruck to talk to her so uh
oh stop
no this was the first chance that we had
to meet and work together
so i feel like i've gotten so far ahead
of this but this is a festival a lot of
our viewers out there don't know too
much about your movies so
nikki do you want to do the honors give
the brief synopsis of
off season yes uh off season
is a mysterious
kind of nightmare film about a woman who
gets summoned to this lonely
island town because her mother's grave
has been vandalized
and as she arrives she starts to quickly
realize that things are not what
they seem and she soon becomes trapped
in a horrible nightmare
like you practice that in the mirror for
three hours
five hours a day
uh jocelyn and joe so one of the things
that
i really appreciated about the movie in
general is that it kind of just throws
you into the deep end and
we don't really spend too much time
rehashing the history between your
characters
but you still have to convey it so what
kind of prep work does that require
beforehand so
you could sell it but without saying it
all the best most fun kind of prep work
i mean
um talking to mickey ahead of time i
think we had a few months
between when i was cast in the film and
when we shot i also was out in l.a so
jocelyn and i were able to get lunch and
and build some backstory for these
characters and then also
like mickey was saying it's so nice to
be able to um shoot with some sense of
chronology so over the course of the
first few days of shooting jocelyn and i
were able to build a lot of that in real
time
to stretch out these um long car
sequences and some of these other
moments where
that tension um wants to feel palpable
but also little bits of dialogue want to
inform the audience
a bit about who these people are and
what's going on so we built a backstory
where
um you know we were dating or there was
some sort of um
chemistry in new york and then a long
period of a break
between us which i was um a little more
confused about than
she was and then um she needs
a companion or someone to accompany her
on this
trip down to florida and invites me
so it's kind of um in our minds was the
first time
we had seen each other in several weeks
and suddenly we're in a car for two days
and all you know these tensions are kind
of like um boiling to the surface
and so we had a ton of fun just um
trying to map out and track that
relationship and also to figure out
amongst these silences and these kinds
of creepy moments like when we were
going to use language and dialogue
what little references could we give to
try and catch the audience up or fill
them in on
who we were it excites me that literally
none of that is
necessarily stated in the movie but i
could i could actually genuinely feel
exactly what you were describing and if
i had to describe the history that's
probably uh right along the lines of
what i would have just said so
job very well done and that depends
for for both of you guys individually
now is there any particular
trait or quality about your characters
that wound up being the
the core or the anchor of sorts
i mean mickey and i talked about that
marie is someone who
she kind of wants to go it alone so this
is kind of playing it into what joe is
just saying about you know
they have a history but maybe she's not
she just doesn't like to be vulnerable
she doesn't like to open up
so um i think she's also maybe someone
who doesn't want to be just defined by
her mom you know like that's really what
we know about marie in this movie is
who her mom was um so
there's something bottled up about her
but she also has a temper so that was
fun to play with and that was something
mickey and i talked about that
definitely comes out in like the lawyer
scene or
in a couple scenes with with george as
well so
yeah and the stuff that is between marie
and george is just so much more
interesting to like
play it's not straightforward we it's
complicated
and when things are unspoken and you can
feel it like
it was fun to develop that you also have
a good deal of
heavy lifting to do in one scene with a
lot of
exposition so when you're delivering i i
guess kind of like a monologue almost
straight to camera or at least during
some beats what kind of prep work can
you do
to ensure that when the time comes to
deliver that it's coming across
naturally and in such an engaging manner
which again i think you do
oh thank you yeah it's daunting and it's
exciting you know to have a scene like
that it's
it's a great gift for an actor to be
able to try to pull something like that
off but it's also scary
because it's so tight and it's directly
you know you're speaking
almost with the camera as george um
so it was it's similar it's akin to what
we're talking about about like really
preparing
and then letting it go when you get on
set and just trying to live in it
speaking of the camera mickey do you and
mac just have it
all down to a science at this point or
is there anything drastically different
about your collaboration on this one
um no i mean we're at this point we're
like a a married couple we don't have to
i send him
so many references and i show him my my
little drawings
and then this one we really were able to
talk about okay we know we can
actually map it out for the time of day
now right
uh there's there's moments we talked a
lot about shooting during magic hour and
so
we have this kind of communication and
and the nice thing is is working with
someone for so long
if something does not work or a shot's
just not going to happen
it's like all right let's figure out
exactly the intention and the emotion we
want to
evoke but let's make it practical to
where we're shooting because none of
these
were sets i mean the house that jeremy
lives in was like
was like built in the 1800s it was all
kind of lopsided on the foundation
you get like seasick in there so uh you
know it really was the effort of
communicating and talking through these
real life places
uh so yeah we we've got a great
relationship uh
i can't sing his praises enough
are you ever on set and having a tough
day or running into a challenge and the
two of you look at each other and go
well at least it wasn't as bad as that
day on that film
i will tell you what this movie had the
single hardest day of any film
we shot a whole movie in maine during
the blizzard and this movie had
one of the worst days of weather i think
i've ever
encountered in my life it was like it
was literally like 30 degrees and 30
mile an hour winds and it was dialogue
and
you know the sea breeze kept you know
just hitting us in the face
and a whole time i was like they came
down here i dragged them all down here
if
i show that i'm upset right now or that
i feel like i'm gonna pass
out uh you know it's gonna ruin the
whole vibe and so
we really like i feel like that was like
the ultimate hardship so now
we can look back and be like at least
this wasn't like off season where we all
almost got
swept away by uh by the violent florida
winds
jocelyn and joe if you could go back to
the very beginning of the shoot and give
yourselves one piece of advice as far as
dealing with the elements while filming
what would it be and why
my wardrobe was um actually perfect for
that day i have to say i
um the first day of shooting it was so
hot
and i was just sweating non-stop but the
day that mickey's talking about i was
like
actually quite comfortable i got to be
in the car
i was in a nice warm outfit um
so i i just was um surfing all the
different
um waves of the shoot and that's the
thing about florida it's
very unpredictable um weather and having
lived in
um florida for a period of time when i
was younger
i kind of knew we were walking into an
environment that you know you just kind
of take it on its own
um merit so i was ready for the
ups and downs i i honestly had a great
time
on the set and um that any technical
issues that came along i really thought
this crew was
totally on top of it i was really
impressed by everybody a great energy
and spirit
so i would say to myself um looking back
go do the movie again
i second that um yeah i honestly like no
there were it was such a delightful
shoot to be on
um i and mickey really just gave me a
lot of courage
moving forward you know he you feel
scared to do things that you haven't
done
for instance that that monologue but he
really was just
so encouraging and so supportive so um
i'm gonna take his vibes with me no
matter who i'm working with
bringing up how good this crew was makes
me think of a question that i used to
ask all the time i haven't asked
recently but if you had a name
an unsung hero of this production
because it's like we know you guys we
know the director
but who is just someone who i don't know
helped you out maybe in an unexpected
way
in uh on a tough day of filming oh
uh well i mean everyone everyone the the
the guys who ran the fog machines were
super patient
considering that uh they would short out
that i would
ask for places to be completely
enveloped in fog because i didn't want
to do
too much digital fog and uh and they did
it i
mean and then the other unsung hero to
an ex is always my editor valerie i mean
she
definitely is able to kind of absorb all
the footage and and really take things
that were the intention and really make
them work so in my mind i mean she's
she's the co-author of all of my films
and she definitely
you know especially like the car crash
sequence is a perfect example it's like
that was that song that i really loved
and i had not thought of it
that way to be almost this big musical
moment and then when she cut it together
she's just like why not this and then
i had to beg warner order music to let
me use the song
and it totally worked out um so yeah so
those are the people i think
you know ev everyone you know we're we
have this luxury of it being a small
enough production
that everyone contributes no one's just
sitting around you know
guarding the generator uh and so
everyone
from from you know across the board
really killed it on this film
in addition to jocelyn and joe your
whole supporting ensemble here is
something else from
like richard brake who's just like
perfectly cast in that role but then
also
you have an actor like the one who plays
miss emily who
i looked up on imdb and that this is the
only credit on her page so
what was it like finding the folks to
fill those roles with your casting
director
oh yeah i mean what we definitely wanted
we realized pretty early on that we
wanted
kind of you know the surrounding
characters to be these authentic
you know to feel authentic and feel
florida and you know
really kind of fit that southern gothic
tone and uh yeah april linscott she came
out of nowhere
and she was just so glorious as miss
emily and then
obviously melora i've been such a fan of
hers for
forever i mean she's one of my heroes as
an actor and i
literally i was like please laura
whatever we could do to
make this work i'll do anything and she
was very great
i'm very proud of everybody they just ah
when i can just like worship the actors
that's my dream and everyone crushed it
on this movie
you you should be mighty proud to end
here
i'm kind of bringing back a question for
you mickey that i think i've asked you
in almost every single interview and i
don't even know it's necessarily what
you want but i keep waiting for the day
when you get
just this enormous budget to work with
you're on a studio platform where
everyone out there you get the widest
possible audience for your work
is that anything that could possibly be
on the horizon and if not
what's just the next i guess the next
big step in your craft that you might
want to tackle with a future film
um yeah i mean sure it's definitely i've
i've done a couple
studio projects and scripts that haven't
obviously gone um
but it's very nice to to get paid or to
write a script for a studio
um but i you know i think the directors
that i look towards are someone you know
are the coen brothers or
you know someone like uh joe uh you know
who
kind of worked the way up to get bigger
and bigger and bigger budgets and you
know
bring along this huge ensemble and and
continuously make things to push the
envelope and i think that's the great
thing about this movie is
i always say i want my my movies to look
to make the previous ones look like
postage stamps you know
look the size and poses him and i
definitely feel like this movie
was by the end of it we i poured
everything into it now all i want to do
is make sure that people see how big you
know florida can look on on screen
as much as you are pulling that off i
still quite love everything that came
before this one but
huge congratulations on off season to
all of you for all of our viewers out
there
make sure to keep an eye out for it i
think you're going to dig it and in the
meantime just
i don't know i can't rattle off every
title go search mickey's name on imdb
and pick
any of those films on his filmography
and you are
all set again guys congratulations thank
you so much
thanks barry